J'ai du bon sens à partir du moment où elle est
née la fille d'un homme est le centre de
son univers tu lui donnes de l'amour tu lui donnes des
encouragements tu la regardes
devenir une femme forte et confiante et puis
un jour tu te retrouves face à face avec l'
amour d'elle  la vie non les
lemmings sont dans la maison oui oh mon
dieu on dirait qu'il travaille pas mal
pas vous les amenez ici s'il vous plait les pieds
s'il vous plait une petite
surprise  oh j'ai donné au gars que
la voiture de Noël ne savait pas qu'il avait mis de joyeuses
fêtes là-bas, je suppose que c'est sur moi
pour toujours maintenant, il s'avère que son petit ami
est ce milliardaire Internet Laird n'a
littéralement pas de filtre mais c'est un très
bon gars, souviens-toi de cette nuit dans le  le
personnel du spa s'est ouvert comme une fleur tu
aurais dû le voir je n'aurais pas dû le
voir mais maintenant j'ai l'impression que oui
aucun père ne voudrait que leur fille avec
ce gars mon instinct est de te serrer dans mes bras
maintenant
bonne nuit je le fais  je ne sais pas quels sont les problèmes
ou Oh ma maison j'ai l'impression d'être si normal
je n'aime pas les gardes du corps alors je viens de
demander à Gustav de m'entraîner ces étranges au fur
et à mesure qu'ils viennent le temps de réaction
augmente ce qui est arrivé à l'évasif Paco
fou je suis le jour de Noël je vais demander à
Stephie de m'épouser et j'aime vraiment
ta bénédiction
tu sais donne moi juste quelques jours quand
tu viendras le matin de Noël tu
vas m'appeler fils je vais
t'appeler papa  ne pense pas que ça va
arriver je pense que ça va papa je sais que ce
ne sera pas papa ce n'était rien mais papa que
ça arrête ce papa de quoi tu
parles oui siree Bob
tu pourrais sortir avec n'importe qui pourquoi Laird il
me rend vraiment heureux
il  enroule ses tentacules autour de
chaque membre de sa famille à cause de
son influence ta mère a perdu la
tête
ça s'appelle bâcher ce n'est pas quelqu'un que
nous voulons que notre fille se marie je vais
abattre cette pieuvre tu vas dire
tout ce qui concerne définitivement le
la proposition a conduit Laird à espionner o  n nous
attends ne plaisante pas avec moi
Oh